[Music]
this is real Martha Stewart is on
match.com she even made a video about
what she's looking for in a man check it
out
I'm Martha Stewart and I've been blessed
with a wonderful life and I'd like to
share that life with a special man I'm
looking for confidence self-reliance a
man who can take control when I tell him
to but I'm also looking for passion sex
will take place every 44 days and last
precisely 12 and a half minutes coitus
will occur in one of two approved
positions family life set in a
hollowed-out heirloom artichoke as for
condoms only natural purebred lambskin
condoms and they're surprisingly easy to
make have your butcher set aside of
these food plant casings and rinse them
under cold water for three minutes
stretch the casings on your condom mold
if you don't have a condom loaded you
can order one from the website and while
the casings to the floor you want to
keep them moist with a spray of olive
oil I go with a light first press
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it goes on for two more hours I want to
know where the hot glue comes into it it
was a hot glue gun and learn Martha's
kinky yeah